[Música]
spectrum
de dónde venimos y adónde vamos estas
son las grandes preguntas que se ha
hecho la humanidad desde el inicio de su
historia son las preguntas que
demuestran la marcada curiosidad que
tiene nuestra especie en nuestro afán de
siempre buscar a saber más de conocer
más acerca de nosotros mismos y del
mundo que nos rodea ahora bien de dónde
venimos nos ayuda a saber sobre nuestro
pasado nuestro origen mientras que a
dónde vamos nos permite vislumbrar el
futuro nuestro destino estos son los dos
extremos de la existencia humana y
responder a estas preguntas podría
cambiar para siempre el paradigma de
nuestra mentalidad
entonces qué pasaría si les dijera que
estamos cerca de responder a una de
estas grandes preguntas hoy vengo a
hablarles de las pistas clave que nos
podrían llevar a responder a de dónde
venimos cómo es esto posible a través de
un principio fundamental un principio o
propiedad que tiene nuestro universo y
que podría ayudarnos a explicar una
forma clara y simple el origen de la
vida
a esta propiedad se le conoce como
emergencia que viene de la palabra
emerger no de la emergencia que
significa peligro y en su forma más
sencilla se puede descubrir cómo la
propiedad en la cual una entidad
cualquier entidad u objeto tiene
características o propiedades distintas
que los objetos o los elementos que la
componen
así de simple esta propiedad está en
todo nuestro universo y es la
responsable de que los átomos no sean
solamente pequeños conjuntos aislados
sino que sean capaces de unirse y
generar sistemas tan complejos como lo
somos nosotros
y cómo es esto podemos verlo desde una
perspectiva de arriba hacia abajo en
nosotros mismos los seres humanos
estamos hechos de sistemas nervioso
cardiovascular respiratorio etcétera
cada uno de estos sistemas está hecho de
órganos cada órgano está conformado por
células las células están hechas de
moléculas proteínas y otros componentes
cada uno de ellos está formado por
átomos y cada átomo está formado por
partículas subatómicas y hay físicos que
dicen que algunas teorías llevan más y
más abajo a qué es lo que componen las
partículas subatómicas pero entonces
independientemente de en qué nivel nos
detengamos lo que tenemos son pequeñas
unidades básicas que conforman algo más
grande que ellas y que tienen
propiedades distintas lo podemos ver con
los átomos que tienen propiedades muy
distintas que los seres humanos que
tenemos la capacidad de pensar de sentir
de soñar de imaginar alguna vez se han
preguntado cómo es posible que algo tan
elemental como es un átomo pueda dar
lugar a una complejidad como la nuestra
tenemos la respuesta a esta pregunta la
punta de la lengua y les voy a decir por
qué
científicos que han estudiado por años
en diseños y modelos matemáticos que
exhiben esta propiedad de la emergencia
entonces se han detectado algunas
categorías en específico de la
emergencia a las cuales los científicos
han bautizado como autómatas celulares
autómata viene de autónomo y celular se
refiere al comportamiento que se parece
a una célula entonces que son los
autómatas celulares son un tipo de
sistema dinámico un sistema dinámico es
uno que evoluciona con el tiempo el
universo visto desde esta perspectiva es
un sistema dinámico porque evoluciona
con el tiempo al igual que la vida
entonces la vida también es un sistema
dinámico por lo tanto
y el conjunto de autómatas celulares son
sistemas dinámicos que exhiben la
propiedad de la emergencia que emerge
pero al mismo tiempo tienen otra
propiedad fundamental autoorganización
la autoorganización es la capacidad como
dice el nombre de organizarse a sí mismo
lo podemos ver en los ecosistemas los
ecosistemas se organizan a sí mismos con
las plantas y animales para llegar a un
equilibrio
esto es autoorganización a gran escala
pero a pequeña escala también la tenemos
en nuestro cuerpo que está auto
organizado para saber hasta qué punto
llega a las células que definen a cada
uno de nuestros órganos las cuales
cumplen con funciones específicas pero
las células no tienen en sí conocimiento
de todo el sistema por ejemplo las
células de la piel de mi dedo no tienen
conocimiento de lo que pasa en las
células de los nervios de mi pierna o de
las neuronas de mi cerebro y al mismo
tiempo todo nuestro cuerpo como conjunto
es capaz de trabajar en acciones
comandadas por nuestro cerebro como es
posible que tengamos una estructura
altamente organizada pero cuyos
elementos no tienen conocimiento de qué
es lo que ocurre
en otros lugares esto es parte de la
auto-organización y es parte de esa
emergencia
entonces ahora les voy a dar dos
ejemplos de autómatas celulares que
demuestran esta propiedad para que
ustedes las observen y puedan fascinarse
o al menos esa es la intención con ellos
de la misma forma que yo me meta cine y
también que puedan pensar en las
implicaciones
el primer ejemplo se llama la hormiga
del alto en honor a su creador
kris lang ton que lo definió en 1986
es un sistema muy sencillo que podemos
tratar como un juego
tenemos una superficie plana en dos
dimensiones que está cuadriculada así
como esta cuadrícula das las libretas
que nosotros conocemos en una de esos
cuadrados de la cuadrícula vive una
hormiga la hormiga puede moverse un
cuadrado por turno o por paso de tiempo
en cada una de las cuatro direcciones
arriba abajo izquierda o derecha
entonces ya sabemos dónde vive la
hormiga lo que sigue es saber cómo se
comporta todo este sistema este juego
que podemos llamar tiene dos reglas
sencillas
hay que pensar que los cuadrados de la
cuadrícula pueden ser blancos o negros
si la hormiga está pisando en este
instante un cuadrado blanco lo que va a
ser el siguiente instante de tiempo o el
siguiente turno es girar 90 grados a la
derecha avanzar un cuadrado y cambiar el
color del cuadrado que dejó a negro
porque estaba en blanco en caso
contrario si el hormiga estaba pisando
un cuadrado negro lo que va a hacer es
girar 90 grados hacia la izquierda
avanzar un cuadrado y cambiar el color
en este caso hablar con las reglas son
muy sencillas entonces piso blanco giro
derecha piso negro giro izquierda en
cualquiera de los dos casos avanzo y
cambio el color del cuadrado anterior
con un comportamiento tan sencillo como
este uno pensaría que la hormiga va a
tener un comportamiento muy determinado
muy sencillo nosotros pensaríamos en
todo caso que la hormiga se mueve con un
patrón definido o en todo caso que hace
un cierto conjunto de figuras pero
siempre predecibles no es así vamos a
verlo en acción
como podemos ver al inicio es como
nosotros lo habíamos definido la hormiga
comienza caminando y podemos predecir
cuál es el siguiente paso que va a dar
porque observamos cuál es el cubo que
tiene abajo o el cuadrado si es blanco o
negro y qué es lo que va a ser
y aquí viene la parte interesante
conforme avanza más el tiempo la hormiga
empieza a volverse impredecible en su
comportamiento cada vez más impredecible
lo que estamos contemplando aquí es el
principio de la emergencia en acción
donde la hormiga está siguiendo reglas y
propiedades distintas a las que nosotros
le dimos si recuerda decimos dos reglas
sencillas en la hormiga y está siendo un
comportamiento cada vez más complejo y
aquí viene la otra parte fascinante la
hormiga está ha sido un comportamiento
cada vez más complejo caótico estamos
generando caos a partir de dos reglas
simples generación de caos a partir de
simplicidad ahora bien es importante
pensar en el caos desde otro punto de
vista porque los seres humanos estamos
acostumbrados a ver el caos como algo
negativo algo que se asocia a momentos
difíciles o sobre los cuales no tenemos
control sobre nuestras propias vidas
pero el caos tiene que siempre ser
negativo
hay que diferenciar desorden de caos el
caos desde el punto de vista de las
matemáticas al menos se define con la
siguiente explicación comportamiento
determinísticos con alta sensibilidad a
las condiciones iniciales es una
definición bastante compleja al inicio
así que vamos a verla por partes
comportamiento determinísticos se
refiere al comportamiento en el que
nosotros sabemos causa y efecto entonces
el caos no es impredecible en el sentido
de que no sepamos cuál es la causa y el
efecto si lo sabemos ahora la segunda
característica del caos y esto es lo
importante
alta sensibilidad a las condiciones
iniciales esto significa que nuestro
sistema es muy sensible a cualquier
modificación que le hagamos y puede
confíar cambiar su configuración en el
futuro de una forma no prevista ese es
el caso entonces en el caso de la
hormiga del acto tenemos la definición
de caos porque nosotros tenemos el
conocimiento de que es la causa y el
efecto pero se tiene un comportamiento
muy complejo y ahora bien pensando en
esto el caos tiene que ser malo
en este caso el caos genera figuras
complejas abstractas y con una belleza
intrínseca y además de eso viene algo
fascinante y llega un punto en la
hormiga del acto donde el caos alcanza
un punto crítico el caos se convierte en
orden así como del orden nació el caos a
partir de este nuevo orden
la hormiga se va a continuar moviendo en
diagonal por el resto de su tiempo los
siguientes turnos esto es increíble y me
recuerda a una frase dicha por carl jung
uno de los iniciadores del psicoanálisis
que nos dice que en todo
caos hay un cosmos en todo desorden un
orden secreto y ese orden secreto podría
ser la vida misma
ahora voy a darles el segundo ejemplo de
autómata celular
este caso es parecido a la hormiga del
actor pero un poquito más complejo en
sus reglas se conoce como el juego de la
vida y fue desarrollado por el
matemático jon conway en 1970
este juego vive aproximadamente en el
mismo mundo que la hormiga del actor
también tenemos una superficie en dos
dimensiones cuadriculada con cuadrados
que pueden ser blancos o negros la
diferencia aquí está en que los
cuadrados negros los podemos considerar
como vivos y los cuadrados blancos como
sin vida
porque esa es la diferencia hasta ahora
por lo tanto este modelo es capaz de
simular comportamientos no solamente
para una entidad sino para varias a la
vez ahora vamos a ver cuáles son las
reglas de este juego cada turno o paso
de tiempo que pasa se evalúa un cierto
conjunto de reglas las cuales son si
tenemos un cuadrado negro o vivo siempre
va a tener a su alrededor 8 otros
cuadrados por simple geometría son sus
vecinos ahora si esta célula tiene
exactamente dos o tres vecinos vivos lo
que va a seguir en el siguiente paso del
tiempo es que la célula permanece viva
pero si tiene menos de dos vecinos la
célula va a morir por falta de población
y en un caso parecido si la célula tiene
más de 44 o más vecinos vivos la célula
va a morir por sobrepoblación
eso es el caso de la célula viva pero si
la célula no está viva y tiene a su
alrededor exactamente tres vecinos vivos
la célula va a nacer o vivir en el
siguiente turno se va a convertir de
blanco a negro esto lo podemos asociar
con una población estable capaz de
reproducirse esas son las reglas del
juego de la vida al igual que el caso
contrario podemos ver un comportamiento
muy distinto de lo que nosotros
pensaríamos pero aquí viene la parte
interesante este caso específico no
solamente depende de cuáles son las
reglas sino también de las condiciones
iniciales podemos ver este juego en
acción en algunas configuraciones cómo
está las células mueren después de unos
cuantos turnos pero existen otras
configuraciones como esta otra donde las
células son capaces de mantenerse vivas
por un tiempo indefinido
y lo más interesante viene con
configuraciones como la que vemos en
pantalla en la cual las células son
capaces de generar entre comillas
organismos más complejos que son capaces
de mantener su forma y moverse en el
espacio estamos generando entre comillas
vida más inteligente o más compleja a
partir de reglas sencillas
incluso hay configuraciones como esta
otra donde los organismos pueden
reproducirse y generar más complejos
ahora bien este es otro ejemplo de la
creación de una complejidad que emerge
de reglas sencillas
el ejemplo de la hormiga del acto y el
del juego de la vida de conway se
desarrollaron en una época donde nuestra
capacidad computacional era muy limitada
y también la memoria de las computadoras
y también las pantallas para visualizar
las simulaciones hoy en día tenemos
súper computadoras tenemos computadoras
personales increíblemente potentes y
tenemos cómputo cuántico en auge que
podría pasar con esas tecnologías que
nos podría llevar a generar algo como el
juego de la vida de conway pero mucho
más complejo que se acerque a nuestra
realidad
esto no está tan lejos de convertirse en
una realidad
nosotros en los años 70 fuimos capaces
de simular algo tan complejo como un
organismo en el juego de la vida de
conway o la generación de caos a partir
del orden y la generación de orden a
partir del caos en la hormiga del actor
origen el libro de autor estadounidense
dan brown nos habla de un personaje que
es capaz de demostrar con computación el
origen de la vida esto no está tan lejos
de convertirse en una realidad con
nuestros modelos computacionales
avanzados que se acerquen más a las
reglas físicas podríamos ser capaces de
demostrar el origen de la vida y esto
podría cambiar para siempre a nuestra
especie porque sería trascendental para
la biología tendríamos una perspectiva
nueva de la vida esta definición de vida
a partir de condiciones iniciales se
conoce como bio génesis en la cual la
vida puede surgir de forma natural por
formas orgánicas
esto es una teoría pero se ha validado
anteriormente por experimentos como el
experimento de miller en el cual se
generaron moléculas orgánicas
moléculas inorgánicas con las
condiciones iniciales adecuadas le suena
familiar esto es exactamente la
definición de la teoría del caos
condiciones iniciales que con alta
sensibilidad pueden dar paso a un
comportamiento complejo entonces una vez
logrado esto nosotros podemos pensar en
la segunda gran pregunta a dónde vamos
porque es muy sencillo los seres humanos
llevan años en la búsqueda de vida en
otros planetas con estas capacidades
podríamos ser capaces de conocer cómo se
forma la vida bajo qué condiciones
iniciales y podríamos buscar el origen
de la vida en otros mundos
estamos en un momento emocionante para
la comunidad científica internacional
porque se están haciendo descubrimientos
cada vez a una tasa más elevada y con
mayor grado de certeza así como tenemos
nuevas herramientas y nuevos modelos
estoy convencido de que en un momento no
tan lejano seremos capaces de responder
a las grandes preguntas que siempre nos
hemos hecho para hacer lo que los seres
humanos hacemos mejor seguirnos
preguntando cosas